In contrast, in paravirtualized systems,
the operating system knows that it's
executing in a virtualized environment.
Because of this, there is no
longer a strict requirement for
the guest OS to use contiguous
physical memory that starts at zero.
And the guest OS can explicitly
register the page tables that it uses
with the hypervisor so there is no
need for maintaining dual page tables,
one of the guest and then another
shadow one at the hypervisor level.
Now, the guest still doesn't have write
permissions to this page table that's
now used by the hardware because
otherwise the guest potentially can
establish any mapping and corrupt other
VMs that are running on the same system.
So, because of that, every update to
the page table would cause a trap and
pass control to the hypervisor.
But because the guest
is paravirtualized, and
we can modify the guest and
do tricks like batch a number of
page table updates and then issue
a single hypercall in this case to
tell the hypervisor to install
all of these mappings.
So this can amortize the cost of
the exit across multiple operations.
There can be other
optimizations that are useful.
For instance, optimizations related
to how the memory's managed so that
it's more friendly to execution in a
virtualized environment or so that it's
more cooperative with respect to other
VMs in the system and other things.
One thing to note that the two
mechanisms that I described with respect
to memory virtualization for
both full as well as para,
paravirtualized VMs have
substantially been improved
given advances in the new
hardware architectures.
So, some of these overheads have
completely been eliminated or
at least substantially reduced if
we take a look at what's happening
at the newer generation
of x86 platforms.
And we will talk about that
shortly in this lesson.